Siena: Good afternoon. My name is Sienna, and this task is, you will record record goose, a goose sighting.
Siena: and I'm going to give you the slug.
Siena: which is cattle, Patsy Catty, India, UOCI. Hyphen, hyphen, Cavar, Capus, TRGS. Hyphen, hyphen, 1, 1, 2, right parenthesis er 12 is the last
Siena: number. So it's 12 R. Ds, UOCI. Python, hyphen, RGS. Tab, patchy tabas, hyphen, hyphen, 1, 2 12
Siena: is the slug, and for this test I'll be using a Mac running the latest version of Macos Sonoma, and the chrome web browser.
Siena: So my task is to navigate the page and enter
information about the type of goose that I spotted.
Siena: So here we go. I will now navigate to the page. Okay, so I'm going to actually go to the top of the page here.
Siena: and I will navigate by pressing control option. Right? Arrow first. I'll see if there's a heading heading
that's awesome. There's a heading that allows me to jump directly to the information, and if I go to the top like.
Siena: there's also a skip to main content button. So I'm gonna or link rather. So I'm going to click on it. Hang on record a second.
Siena: And it brought me right down to that heading as well. So that's that's awesome. Right from the start. There's
Siena: 2 ways in which I can jump directly to the navigation. I have the option of using the skip to main content, which works very, very well
and I can also use my navigate by heading command, which is control option. Command H.
Siena: To go to the, to jump directly to the heading. So both work equally well.
Siena: and that's great that you have
both on the site because it gives the user the ability to choose so, for example, I tend to like the skip to main content. But
Siena: using the headings is equally useful for me and for a voiceover user, we have the ability to choose which method we prefer.
Siena: So I'm gonna navigate through the page. Use the service. So listen, Bullet, tell us you like these, one or 3 bullet. Tell us type of news. You saw 2 or 3 bullet the data which you saw the ghost.
Siena: Okay? And so this is very clear. So I'm going to keep navigating control option, right arrow and a list. Start now, button.
Siena: Here is the start now, Button. It's clearly labeled. I will now activate it by pressing control option space like skip to me, content like skip to me content. And I'm gonna and I'm gonna use the
Siena: skip to main content link at the top of the page and the one do you like these. And here we go.
So like, ask you like these.
Siena: yes, radio 1, 1, 2 selected. I do like geese. So I'm going to select. Yes, yes.
no, really. 1, 2, 2, no! Continue. Button.
Siena: and I will click the continue button. blink to me content, blink to me content. See those goose, and here we go. What type of goose did I see those goose
go to Group Angle one. What type 2 CC, go to scoop, go, choose, use. end of those goose group tell us what type of goose was. Teletype boosting slacks reduce any text. tell us what kind of ghost goes to sc group
does goes end of goes goes group ghost goes teletype, boost wax. We're induced by text name.
Siena: And now I'm ready to type in what goose type of goose I saw. So I'm gonna say, Canada goose
continue what counts instruction attacks. Tell us what type of booze was. Kind of ghost goose proof those goose dos goose proof
Siena: kind of the one. What's that? Goose? Easy now? I'm not sure what it means here by ghost goose
Siena: group. However, when I click on it by pressing control. Option, space, cannabis instruction kind of text telephone. It brings me right to the edit field, which is what I would expect
Siena: and what type of goose it? What? Tell? Tell us what type of goose it was I typed in Canada. Goose, continue button, and there's the continue button.
Siena: Link, skip me, content. Link, skip to me content wind didn't see the goose group angle one when didn't see the goose? For example, when did you see the goose? 16, 4, 2,017 today. Come on, come on by the text here, here at the tax. Continue. Okay. So this is very
Siena: straightforward. Here. So I'm gonna
month mock dag day, for example, 1640,017.
Siena: Go to the I'm going to go to the day field.
Great good talk.
Siena: And I'm going to say I'm going to use.
Siena: So for the day I'm gonna put
Siena:  0
Siena: 4
Siena: month month month, any text month. I'm gonna put 0 3
here here. Okay.
Siena: and 2024.
And when did you see this group? Continue? Button like sifting content, like sifting, content? Name hangout, hanging all 3 boo details. Dimension, the volumes you like these, 1, 3, yes, 2 of 9. Link changes, 3 of 9.
Siena: And I'm just going to refer to my instructions. Yeah, description, scenario flexibility and usability issues. You don't need to worry about the values you are entering answers new line task. Once pages. Select now and answer the question with information. Once on their answers on this page, strike, change your answer to the type of goose you saw. After completing your answers, you can submit your application. The task ends here.
Siena: Okay, so now it is time to revise my answers, so I will now. Yes, do it on
Siena: See how I go about doing that. I will continue to navigate. Link, change biscuits. 390, and it says, change links, windows, words, link, change biscuits, biscuits, character. VISC, UITS, okay, change biscuits. So I think.
Siena:  there, I would just put change for the link. However, the link is clearly labeled.
and
Siena: I would be able to click on it to change it. Let's see if it's the same for the
type of goose type of gooseberries off. 2 or 3 counted goose, 5 of 9, link K. 6, 9,
Siena: and it says, change cake here. But the label is clear and it's a clickable link. So I'll be able to activate it by pressing control, option, space
Siena: and link change. Take. You saw the goose 9 9, of course. Take. You saw the goose link change. Take 6. Okay, so I'm going to
Siena: click the change on the I'm going to click change on the
Siena: type of goose link, skip to me content like Skipton, and let's see if I'll be able to change it. Go to Sc group
teletype, boost, reduce pay tax
Siena: and teletype teletype of those things wax reduced any text
Siena: and I'll change it back. Continue one teletype to Canada. Goose.
continue button teletype boost. Max reduced text. Select all.
Siena: I'm going to say Canada goose.
continue button like sift any content like sift any content name. When did you see panel? What? When did you see the goose, for example, 64,000 pengund main link sift any content like skip to me. Contact me. When did you see Pendle? One windows videos, for example, C. 4. Day text.
Siena: I'll go back and put the day. So I saw the goose today. 0 4.
Come on better text.
Siena: 0 3 per month, and I'm just tapping through, and it's working very well, using voiceover 2024. And now I will tab to the continue button. Continue button main link. Excuse me, Content Link. Excuse me, and I'm going to revise my answers. Main heading one, heading, all 3. Boosty tells division this items U likeies 1, 3, yes, 2, and a link changes. Type of goose. You saw 2 for Canada. Goose 5, and Link change. Take. You saw the goose, of course. 535-20-2489. Blink, change the cake. You saw the goose and divisionus.
Siena: and if I were to click on this link, I'll be able to change the date that I saw the goose.
Siena: So now I'm going to go ahead and submit and
head to mouse interoperation. Try something specification. To return that to best your knowledge details, you're providing correct. What happens, my dear collapse. Destroy your triangle group.
Siena: And now there's a what happens with my data link. I'm going, or it's a collapsible item. So I'm going to expand it. What happens? My data expand your triangle group? Nothing. This is actually difficult anything you have to store your own record, unfortunately
continue button
Siena: and
Siena: that works very well. The
Siena: collapsible item. Works very well. With voiceover. It tells me whether the item is collapsed or expanded, and when I expanded it it indicated that it was expanded, and I was able to read the information inside that collapsible item.
Nothing, continue button.
Siena: And so I'm going to hit the continue button. Who's recorded recordings like Link, skip to me, content link skip to me content. Hango on! And Voiceover gave me the confirmation right away when I clicked on it that the goose sighting was recorded.
Siena: And so here we go. I'm going to
Siena: right on the top here it in this heading I went backwards by headings, and it said.
Goose
Siena: recorded don't have, and the one who's recorded don't have a number
education 1, 2, 4, yeah.
Siena: And I was able to read the yet reference number without any issues. We received information
to get the same descriptions, open the content menu, unlimited penalty to finish reciprocal exercise.
Siena: And here we go. Did you think you found all these issues, including ones on this page.
Link, take a look at the answers period. Or, if you want another check, go back to starting
Siena: like. And interestingly, I didn't find any issues as far as accessibility is concerned. As far as usability. With voiceover.
the buttons were actually very clearly labeled.
Siena: and I was able to access all of the information. Really without any difficulties, all of the buttons, all of the links.
Everything was clearly labeled, and I was able to
Siena: activate them
Siena: without any issues. All of the edit fields were clearly labeled as well. So I knew right away, as I was tabbing through which
Siena: information I needed to put into what which edit field I want to it. It was a great experience, and
I want to thank you so much for your continued support in
Siena: making this website accessible for everyone. It's a great experience with Voiceover, and once again keep up the great work. Thank you so much for watching.